and what else could we do we can also
unlock the secrets of the Big Bang
you see Einstein's equations break down
at the instant of the Big Bang and the
center of a black hole the two most
interesting places in the universe are
beyond our reach using Einstein's
equations we need a higher theory and
that's where string theory comes in
string theory takes you before the Big
Bang before Genesis itself and what does
string theory say it says that there is
a multiverse of universes where do the
Big Bang come from well Einstein
equations give us this compelling
picture that we are like insects on a
soap bubble a gigantic soap bulb which
is expanding and we are trapped like
flies on flypaper we can't escape the
soap bubble and that's called the Big
Bang Theory
string theory says there should be other
bubbles out there in a multiverse of
bubbles when two universes collide it
can form another universe when a
universe splits in half it can create
two universes and that we think is the
Big Bang the Big Bang is caused either
by the collision of universes or by the
fissioning of universities if there are
other dimensions if there are other
universes can we go between universes
well that of course is very hard
however Alice and wonderland gives us a
possibility that maybe one day we might
create a wormhole between universes this
is a wormhole think of taking a sheet of
paper and putting two dots on it the
shortest distance between two points is
a straight line but if I can fold if I
can fold that sheet of paper then
perhaps I can create a shortcut a
shortcut through space and time called a
wormhole
this is a genuine solution of Einstein's
equations we can actually see this in
string theory the question is how
practical is it to go through one of
these things we don't know in fact
there's a debate among physicists today
Stephen Hawking many physicists are
jumping into the game trying to figure
out whether it is physically possible to
go all the way through a worm oh because
if you could then you might be able to
use this as a time machine
since string theory is a theory of
everything it's also a theory of time
and time machines are allowed in
Einstein's equations but to build one is
extremely difficult far more energy is
required than a simple DeLorean with
plutonium
you know trillions of years from now the
universe is going to get awfully cold we
think the universe is headed for a big
freeze all the stars will blink out
stars will cease to twinkle the universe
will be so big it'll be very cold at
that point all intelligent life in the
universe must die the laws of physics
are a death warrant to all intelligent
life there's only one way to escape the
death of the universe and that is leave
the universe we are now of course
entering the realm of science fiction
but at least we now have equations the
equations of string theory which will
allow us to calculate if it is possible
to go through a wormhole to go to
another universe where it's warmer and
perhaps we can start all over again